bonsoir lundi 8 mars bienvenue pour
cette nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 60,18 voici les titres de
ce journal c'est la journée
internationale des droits des femmes un
moment pour se souvenir des combats
féministes et pour faire un bilan sur la
situation des femmes
l occasion aussi pour nous de parler de
cette thématique d'hier à aujourd'hui
invités de cette édition catherine
leconte professeur en histoire du droit
à lui vs cul et sophie bar du collectif
ne tout 78 la venue de marlène schiappa
dans les yvelines la ministre déléguée
auprès du ministre de l'intérieur était
un rambouillet elle a annoncé les
résultats de l'audit sur l'accueil en
commissariats et brigades de gendarmerie
des victimes de violence conjugale et
les résultats sont plutôt intéressants
enfin les yvelines une nouvelle fois
rampe de lancement du paris-nice
l'édition 2000 21 s'est ouverte hier
avec une étape au départ et à l'arrivée
de saint cyr l'école ce matin les
coureurs se sont élancés drainville sur
mansion avant de quitter le département
mais avant de développer ces titres ce
nouvel élément dans la sphère sur
l'assassinât de samuel pâtit le
professeur d'histoire-géographie
décapité le 16 octobre dernier non loin
du collège où il enseignait le bois
d'aulne à conflans sainte honorine est
la collégienne de 13 ans qui a accusé
l'enseignant d'islamophobie a avoué
avoir menti elle a reconnu lors de sa
garde à vue ne pas avoir assisté aux
cours sur la liberté d'expression
celui où samuel patier a démontré des
caricatures du prophète mahomet à ses
élèves elle dans sa version
l'adolescente affirmé que le professeur
avait demandé aux élèves musulmans de
quitter la salle avant de montrer les
caricatures c'est de cette version
amplifiée par le père de la jeune fille
sur internet et qui s'est mué en
polémique qui est parti les l'engrenage
qui a abouti à l'assassinât du
professeur à la collégienne étaient déjà
mises en examen dans cette affaire pour
dénonciation calomnieuse
celui mars c'est la journée
internationale des droits des femmes
c'est la date choisie par la commune de
ben et là par la préfecture des yvelines
pour signer une convention l'objectif
lutter contre les violences sexistes et
sexuelles les précisions d'eléonore
sinoquet c'est une première dans le
département et la date du lundi 8 mars
journée internationale des droits des
femmes n'a pas été choisie au hasard
la ville de ben et la préfecture des
yvelines ont signé ce matin un contrat
de mobilisation et de coordination
locale contre les violences sexistes et
sexuelles
c'est vraiment une action importante sur
le territoire de la commune et c'était
normal qu'en cette journée du 8 mars
l'état souligne par la signature de
cette convention la qualité de cet
engagement
elle a souhaité faire de cette lutte
résolue contre les violences faites aux
femmes un marqueur de son action
municipale objectifs de cette convention
assurer la mobilisation des services
municipaux des associations et les
services de l'état sur le territoire de
bennes pour garantir une protection
efficace contre les violences sexistes
et sexuelles
ce qui est important pour nous c'est la
suite de tout un engagement qui dure
depuis plusieurs années déjà
le but était d'apporter et de dire voilà
une commune s'engage essayé toutes les
communes et je porterai ce discours
ailleurs de s'engager justement et plus
on amplifiera le mouvement plus on aura
de résultats et c'est le but que je me
suis assignées en tant que particulier
avant mais aussi maintenant en tant que
maire cette convention tout comme les
bons taxi qui transportent les victimes
en milieu rural doivent contribuer à la
diminution des faits de violences
sexistes et sexuelles ou comme le maire
de bègles espère les faire disparaître
une journée internationale des droits
des femmes donc en ce 8 mars et depuis
1975 que l'organisation des nations unis
commémorent cette date un événement pour
faire le bilan sur la situation des
femmes et se souvenir aussi des combats
féministes wa 20e siècle on a souhaité
justement parler de ces combats d'hier à
aujourd'hui avec mes deux invités tout
d'abord catherine leconte bonsoir vous
êtes professeur en histoire du droit
doyen doyen honoraire de la faculté de
droit et de science politique de
l'université versailles saint quentin
également en visioconférence sophie bar
bonsoir bonsoir membres du collectif
nous tout soixante dix huit vous en êtes
à l'origine de ce collectif dans les
yvelines et on va justement parler avec
vous des luttes actuelles mais d'abord
place à l'histoire
catherine leconte on connaît bien sûr à
les grandes dates au xxème siècle de
l'histoire des droits des femmes le 21
avril 1944 avec le droit de vote accordé
aux femmes le 13 juillet 1965 avec
l'autorisation pour les femmes à ouvrir
leur compte en banque
en leur nom et aussi à travailler sans
le consentement de leur mari une
dernière date que l'on peut citer le 17
janvier 1975 avec la loi veil légalisant
l interruption volontaire de grossesse
pour les femmes il ya bien sûr d'autres
dates avec vous on va on va remonter un
peu plus loin remontons déjà à l'époque
médiévale pas de notion de droit des
femmes à l'époque mais le rôle des
femmes même dans l'ombre et est déjà
important et est reconnue alors pas de
notion de droits des femmes
oui et non il faudrait pas oublier les
travaux il ne faudrait pas oublier les
travaux qui ont été consacrés depuis une
quarantaine d'années
aux droits des femmes enfin le terme
droit est un peu fort mais c'est celui
que nous utilisons aujourd'hui lorsque
des chercheurs se sont interrogés à la
place de la femme dans la société
romaine donc en pierre romain et à la
place de la femme dans les tous premiers
temps de notre haut moyen-âge médiévale
et sont des travaux qui sont
intéressants parce qu'il pose les jalons
je dis bien les jalons des querelles ou
au contraire des de la symbiose entre
les coutumes locales et le droit romain
qui je n'apprends ça à personne pénètre
dans notre société française en forme de
la qualifiez pas de française mais est
il ya indiscutablement un travail qui a
été fait depuis de longues années pour
essayer de montrer que l'accession des
femmes seins ou l'insertion des femmes
dans un système juridique vient un peu
de ce rapprochement entre les coutumes
locales qu'elles soient du sud du massif
central où qu'elles soient de l'anjou
contribue à forger ce que nous
appellerions aujourd'hui mais c'est bien
prétentieux un statut des femmes
étant entendu qu'à l'époque médiévale la
femme est avant tout paysanne avec tout
ce que ça comporte comme superlatifs et
de péjoratif
elle est souvent sorcières on trouve
toujours dans la littérature les
chansons de geste des sorcières elle
s'occupe des enfants et elle a un rôle
économique non négligeable
si on regarde en plus simple d'un voyage
et si on arrive au tableau de bruegel
nous avons toujours des femmes donc déjà
une présence en tout cas au moyen-âge
sur la question de droit même si on
parle pas de droit des femmes à l'époque
m'avait dit également en off que si on
regarde l'époque révolutionnaire on a
aussi des choses à apprendre de ce conte
irlandais sont à prendre
j'en prendrai pour exemple un livre qui
a été publié
il y a deux cent cinq ou six ans qui
s'appelle les amazones de la révolution
qui ne connaît pas olympe de gouges bon
à l'époque révolutionnaire il ya eu des
travaux qui ont été faits dont les
titres excusez moi on se regarde mes
feuilles parce que je vais pas dire de
bêtise dont les titres sont très
intéressants et apparaissent comme des
titres digne du 21e siècle ou presque
avant la réunion des états généraux et
donc la proclamation des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen on s'intéressait
au 13ème rang donc remontrances des
femmes françaises et un peu plus tard en
1790 un discours sur l'injustice des
lois en faveur des hommes aux dépens des
femmes
donc ça veut dire qu'il y avait quand
même en germe une volonté de dire les
femmes sont là un petit bond dans le
temps ce que l'entretien cours et il
faut il faut aussi avancer pour arriver
au xxème siècle avec finalement les deux
guerres mondiales qui vont changer les
choses
la première ou et les femmes ont dû
travailler pour remplacer des hommes
partis au front dans les yvelines
il ya l'exemple d'une femme la duchesse
d'uzès and de rochechouart de mortemart
qui est retenu dans l'histoire notamment
pour être la première femme à obtenir
son permis de conduire automobile mais
aussi pendant la première guerre
mondiale elle va offrir son château de
bonnel pour organiser assez frêle annexe
de l'hôpital de rambouillet l'hôpital de
chirurgie alors vous parlez de la
duchesse d'uzès
ce qui m'amène à dire que la duchesse
d'uzès en 1898
et c'est d'autant plus amusant que si on
voit des photos de la duchesse d'uzès on
imagine temps la duchesse d'uzès avait
passé a permis de conduire et la 10e 6
aces avait fondé l'union française pour
le suffrage de femmes et l'émancipation
des femmes ont été mobilisés mais elles
s'inscrivent être tout à fait dans un
courant qui était entretenue par les
radicaux avant la guerre de 14
au moment où ils sont au pouvoir dont
fin 19e et les radicaux avaient
multiplié les
et publications sur l'éducation
féministes des filles la femme dans les
endroits publics 7 est indiscutablement
un sujet qui pour eux était extrêmement
important et il prenait comme modèle ça
nous fait rire aujourd'hui ils prenaient
comme modèle
l'admission des femmes dans les postes
et il ya des tonnes de publication sur
le statut des employés de postes et on
pourrait aussi dans la même lignée alors
je fais un grand saut dans le dans le
temps reprendre les travaux de laure
adler d'edmonde charles-roux de
d'elisabeth badinter qui lorsqu'elle
parle de l'enfance et du travail depuis
le moyen-âge et d'emilie et de
l'ambition d'emilie s'appuie sur ces
travaux qui ont été faits au 19e siècle
dont il ya quelque chose de très
important
il ya une espèce de socle là qu'on
exploite sans doute pas assez
si on ne veut pas faire un travail
scientifique sur la question
on a tendance à le donner et dernière
chose on pourrait en parler des heures
bien sûr de cette histoire il ya un
autre exemple pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale avec les femmes qui ont aussi
joué un rôle dans la résistance avec
notamment il à triolet figure on connaît
bien sûr dans les yvelines et au niveau
national l'auteur qui a été la première
femme à recevoir le prix goncourt en
france et dont la demeure était à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines qui a
également oeuvré dans la résistance par
ses actes par ses écrits il ya là la
duchesse d'uzès
je reviens la duchesse d'uzès comme elsa
triolet ou comme bien d'autres on
pourrait citer geneviève anthonioz de
gaulle c'était la seynoise maintenant ce
sont les yvelines
on pourrait citer quelqu'un qui est très
célèbre dans le département c'est madame
fleury la présidente des déportés nous
étions asséné oise est indiscutablement
ces femmes ont eu la volonté de
témoigner de séquelles ont pu faire en
faveur de la résistance est à près de
cultiver cette mémoire
alors on peut dire c'est de la
vieillerie mais ce n'est pas de la
vieille ville
parce que si elle ne cultivait pas cette
mémoire il est possible que les lycéens
aujourd'hui ne comprendrait pas que ces
femmes ont véritablement
étais je reprends le terme que j'ai
utilisé tout à l'heure des femmes
minuscule et sont devenus des flammes
des influences par le travail qu'elles
ont elles ont mis en oeuvre vous si on
s'écarte un peu des yvelines ça peut
être amusant
tandis qu'eux on avez on ouvrait des
hôpitaux militaires dans les yvelines
grâce aux femmes n'oublions pas l'abbaye
de royaumont et les femmes religieuses
médecin anglaises et françaises qui ont
donné à cet hôpital militaire qui
n'était pas loin du front une extension
extraordinaire voilà blues lions pas non
plus excuser moi sur le très rapide et
très rapidement n'oublions pas non plus
ces femmes qui dans les années 1930 1950
ont apporté alors on s'écarte de la
guerre mais ont apporté leur délicatesse
le plat on va dire que j'exagère un peu
laure délicatesse dans le domaine de
l'art n'oublions pas les premières
femmes qui ont fréquenté le bounce
n'oublions pas une marcel tassencourt
avec ça ils femme dé thierry monnier
n'oublions pas toutes celles qui on
avait gagné louise de vilmorin entraîne
malraux un peu plus tard et qui ont
petit à petit c'est progresser la pause
les femmes pourrait on pourra en parler
pendant des heures
je suis désolé mais en tout cas voilà
pour le côté historique avec on l'a
compris ce rôle prépondérant des femmes
qui ont amené aussi à remporter certains
combats mais il en reste encore de
nombreux aujourd'hui sophie bar vous
êtes co animatrice de nous tout 78
justement quels sont les combats actuels
menée notamment par votre collectif
bonsoir c'est vraiment intéressant de
de parler de ce que les femmes tout ce
que les fameux fait dans l'histoire et
qui est un visibiliser aujourd'hui et
moi je le sais bien parce que je suis
professeur de lycée même si là j'ai
repris mes études mais effectivement on
parle très peu des femmes dans les
programmes scolaires et c'est bien
malheureux mais les femmes se sont
battus pour la france et puis elles se
sont battus eux aussi pour leurs droits
et c'est terrible de voir qu'au xxième
siècle les inégalités sont encore
extrêmement forte et extrêmement froides
flagrante malgré ce que beaucoup de gens
pensent donc pour répondre à votre
question à nos tout ce nous militons sur
la question des violences sexistes et
sexuelles et en france il y à un niveau
très élevé de violence envers les femmes
et les enfants
pour vous donner quelques chiffres par
exemple en france aujourd'hui il y à un
viol ou une tentative de viol toutes les
six minutes ça fait 94 milles chaque
année il faut savoir que une immense
majorité des victimes ne portent pas
plainte et que la majorité des teintes
sont classées sans suite
voilà quelques chiffres pour illustrer
ces niveaux d'hier dans cette actualité
justement nous tout distribuer notamment
des violents tôt m et alors l'idée avait
été expérimenté par la mairie
noisy-le-sec dans le 93
celle d'imprimer ces violentes au maître
directement sur les sachets d des
baguettes de pain vous voudriez le voir
imprimé partout en france vous avez
lancé au niveau national une cagnotte
litchi est ce qu'il sera possible
prochainement de voir ces violentes au
maître justement sur sur les les sachets
de ses baguettes de pain est ce que
c'est un projet qui va qui va arriver à
son terme
oui absolument on est en train de
l'organiser donc les yvelinoises et les
yvelinois vont les voir arriver alors
évidemment pas dans toutes les
boulangeries
mais on a environ 80 militantes et
militants dans les yvelines
ou peut-être un peu plus et donc ils
sont en train d'aller contacter les
boulangeries dans leur ville pour leur
proposer de participer à l'opération
il ya déjà un grand
deux boulangeries qui nous ont donné
leur accord il va y avoir six cent mille
sachet qui vont être imprimés sur
l'ensemble de la france qui vont être
répartis sur tous les départements
et d'ici la semaine prochaine on va
commencer à les apporter gratuitement
dans les boulangeries cd sachez qu ont
été imprimés pour respecter les normes
les boulangeries donc en effet ces
sachets vont arriver très bientôt dans
les boulangeries jeu je ne précise
également que cet outil le violent tôt m
c'est un outil qu'on a aussi distribué
dans les rues en février 2020 lors d'une
opération sur plusieurs villes des
yvelines
abba voyez vous merci beaucoup de
diffuser ces images en même temps donc
moi j'étais à saint germain en laye il
ya des versailles a verrouillé il ya des
poissy où il y avait différentes villes
montent également
et on va recommencer au printemps parce
qu'il nous en reste beaucoup et c'est un
outil qui est vraiment très intéressant
parce qu'il montre sur une règle graduée
24 étapes d'une relation saine jusqu'à
une relation de violence à travers un
continuum qui est représenté par des
couleurs du vert jusqu'au rouge parce
que la violence ce n'est pas violent ou
pas violent c'est un continuum qui passe
par des violences psychologiques de
l'emprise de la dévalorisation des
humiliations etc
et c'est un outil qui est également
distribuée dans les lycées parce que à
l'origine il a été développé pour
sensibiliser les lycéennes et les
lycéens à la violence dans les relations
sentimentales entre les jeunes et je
voulais parler aussi des de l'égalité
salariale malheureusement va pas avoir
le temps parce qu'on arrive à la fin de
cet entretien on a voilà on a parlé
énormément
énormément de l'histoire et aussi du
combat de nous tout juste vous rappeler
précise aux téléspectateurs que pour
cette journée internationale des droits
des femmes l'onu a choisi cette année
comme thématique leadership féminin pour
un futur égalitaire dans le monde de la
coved 19 les femmes ont été également en
première ligne de cette épidémie
que ce soit les professionnels de santé
d'autres professions également et
pourtant elles sont payées 11% de moins
que leurs homologues masculins à
l'échelle mondiale et d'ailleurs et ce
sera tout pour cette thématique à vous
préciser également que les députés de la
majorité la république en marche ont
déposé ce 8 mars une proposition de loi
pour accélérer l'égalité économique et
professionnelle entre les femmes et les
hommes parmi les points à retenir l'eau
bègles obligations notamment de verser
le salaire ou les prestations sociales
sur un compte bancaire dont le salarié
est détenteur ou co détenteur ou
également l'accès à des dispositifs de
formation et aussi à des réservations de
places en crèche pour les femmes à la
tête de familles monoparentales voilà on
va clôturer ce chapitre je suis désolé
on arrive est déjà à la fin de cet
entretien merci en tout cas nos deux
invités d'avoir été avec nous catherine
leconte en plateau professeur en
histoire du droit doyen honoraire de la
faculté de droit et de sciences
politiques de lille vs cul et merci
également à vous sophie bar du collectif
de toute façon et on va continuer de
parler de violences conjugales je vous
propose à présent ce sujet je vous en
parlais dans les titres marlène schiappa
ministre délégué auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur était à rambouillet vendredi
5 mars elle est venue annoncer le
résultat de l'audit sur l'accueil en
commissariats et brigades de gendarmerie
des victimes de violence conjugale et
c'était dans le cadre dans la suite du
grenelle des violences faites aux femmes
astrid berges heures pour le sujet
marlène schiappa ministre délégué auprès
du ministre de l'intérieur a dévoilé les
résultats de l'audit sur l'accueil en
commissariats et brigades de gendarmerie
des victimes de violences à rambouillet
vendredi 5 mars
les résultats sont encourageants ce que
nous dit cette eau dit c'est que 90 %
des victimes sont globalement satisfaite
de l'accueil
90% des victimes globalement satisfaite
c'est un chiffre encourageant important
mais qui ne doit pas nous conduire
un visibiliser les 10 % des cas pour
lesquels ça se passe mal et pour
lesquels cela peut conduire à des drames
et à la mort de ces femmes parmi les
autres résultats
75% des victimes trouvent les délais
d'attentes satisfaisant et 80% d'entre
elles ont jugé la confidentialité des
locaux est également satisfaisante par
ailleurs en zone gendarmerie
seuls 43% ont été en contact avec une
intervenante sociale au sein des locaux
de la gendarmerie
ce n'est pas suffisant c'est moins d'une
victime sur deux lorsqu'on connaît la
port et l'importance du rôle des
intervenants sociaux on commence à ria
et en brigades de gendarmerie et leur
travail il est maintenant unanimement
saluée il est mieux connu c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous en renforçant
la cij dans les recrutements
la ministre était à rambouillet à
l'invitation de robert g député de la
10e circonscription des yvelines
le commissariat de police de la ville
n'a pas été choisie au hasard
les agents ayant pris plusieurs
initiatives pour accueillir au mieux les
victimes l'engagement et la bonne
volonté des policiers et des gendarmes
elles sont fondamentales c'est à dire
qu'à partir du moment où il ya des
engagements personnels pour créer pour
innover
on peut avancer c'est le cas par exemple
c'est avec le qr code qui a été créée et
d'initiative marlène schiappa annoncé
que cet audit sur l'accueil jean
commissariats et brigades de gendarmerie
des victimes de violence serait
reconduit chaque année
c'était une promesse de jean castex
accélérer la vaccination dans les
départements surveillance renforcée les
yvelines en font partie lé centres de
vaccination étaient donc ouvert samedi
et dimanche dans le département
5500 doses ont été administrées au cours
des 48 dernières heures est d'ailleurs à
partir de cette semaine quatre nouveaux
centres de vaccination ouvrent dans les
yvelines au menu la crêpière à
sartrouville et à saint cyr l'école ils
viennent s'ajouter aux 9 centres
existants et déjà ouverts sur le
territoire portant le nombre total a13
dans les yvelines nous ferons de temps
sur la vaccination dans notre édition de
demain mardi
avec l' agence régionale de santé une
accélération de la campagne de
vaccination dans un contexte épidémique
toujours tendue dans les yvelines avec
ces derniers chiffres sur une semaine
dans le département le taux de
positivité aux tests restent stables
mais élevée tout comme le taux
d'incidence qui a tout de même baissé
depuis le 28 février
il est désormais à 270 le taux
d'incidence pour rappel c'est le nombre
de nouveaux contaminée pour 100000
habitants à l'hôpital le taux
d'occupation des lits en réanimation
augmente largement il est de 83,7 % en
ile-de-france et dans les yvelines 16
personnes supplémentaires ont été
placées en réanimation entre le 28
février et le 7 mars est 1413 personnes
sont décédées et du colis de 19 dans les
hôpitaux yvelinois depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire
par ailleurs on apprend aujourd'hui que
les établissements de santé franciliens
vont devoir des programmes et 40% de
leurs activités médicales et
chirurgicales pour libérer ajustement
des places en réanimation dans
l'actualité également la disparition
d'olivier à basseau le député de l'oise
est décédé hier soir dimanche dans le
crash de son hélicoptère est le fils de
serge dassault avait fondé en 2002 avec
hervé novelli et jean michel fourgous
présidente saint quentin en yvelines et
génération entreprise c'est une
association regroupant soit 670
parlementaire est de nombreux
représentants politiques lui ont rendu
hommage c'est le cas notamment de
nicolas dainville le maire de la
verrière et le secrétaire général de
l'association
il a été nommé par olivier dassault
propos recueillis par eléonore si nos
quais et mélanie poké olivier delsaux
c'était un homme qui avait mis de
multiples talents mais il avait un
talent littéraire
il avait un talent politique il avait un
talent
humain qui étaient traîtres ils étaient
très très proche des gens il avait un
talent artistique
il prenait des photos assez
extraordinaire il composé lui-même ses
musiques et donc à travers tous ces
talents il aussi mis au service de ses
convictions et notamment pour défendre
l'entreprise et les entrepreneurs
français
et puis du sport pour refermer ce
journal avec ce rendez vous annuel
paris-nice bien sûr qui est à nouveau
partie des yvelines ce dimanche saint
cyr l'école était le théâtre de la
première étape de la course au soleil
dimanche 161 coureurs ont pris le départ
et puis ce matin c'était au tour de la
petite commune doivent ils surent
mention de voir le peloton s'élance et
mélanie poké mickaël mille euros était
sur place
nous sommes à roinville sur mansion dans
le nord des yvelines c'est la 79e
édition du paris-nice le département
accueille ses leçons soleil l2 puis à 12
en blanc qui
[Musique]
hier c'était la commune de saint cyr
l'école qui a ouvert le bal dans les
yvelines mélanie poké étaient sur place
le soleil était au rendez vous ce
dimanche 7 mars les spectateurs un peu
moins nombreux qu'en temps normal
avec la crise de l'accueil de 19 les
amoureux du vélo ont dû accepter leur
frustration paris nice est toujours un
moment dans le début de saison on peut
avoir les nouvelles équipes boire
voir ce qui s'y passe
c'est via une micro vide c'est un peu
plus sportivement cette présentation est
là du coup on attend le début de la
course
on nous a dit de venir par là donc voilà
après les circonstances font que c'est
compliqué quand on est on est très loin
des avec word cette course à huis clos à
l'ambiance particulière s'est lancé à
deux pas du lycée militaire de saint cyr
l'école c'est une vraie opportunité pour
la ville de faire connaître ses
bâtiments historiques l'école militaire
y'a des l'aérodrome mais aussi de
montrer à quel point cette ville elle
est agréable à vivre de vous que dans
les yvelines et l'essonne où les
spectateurs étaient au bord des routes
ou à leurs balcons des images loin
d'être inédite pour le département s'est
diffusé dans plusieurs pays du monde par
plusieurs chaînes une découverte
extraordinaire des idées c'est ça qui
justifie ce partenariat qui dure et qui
durera on est ravi de partir l'essentiel
écoles et à nouveau des yvelines et
comme nous le faisons pour paris nice
depuis chaque année depuis chaque année
depuis 2010 et puis de se projeter pour
une semaine de course magnifique avec un
très beau plateau
après 166 km l'irlandais sam bennett
s'impose devant le champion de france
arnaud démare sur cette première étape
illinoise après saint cyr l'école c'est
au tour de watteville sur mansion
d'accueillir l'épreuve ce lundi 8 mars
cette petite commune du nord des mines
de 1100 habitants organisent pour la
première fois de son histoire le départ
de la course au soleil on a besoin ouais
d'être accueillis dans les villes et
elles le font très bien
yala gratin mondial qui rase et c'est le
charme du vélo de pouvoir faire ça on
pourra port mener le psg jouait vers la
ville sur mention ni l'équipe de france
de football mais on peut emmener les
meilleures records ans et qu'il y ait du
monde
on sait que vous êtes un passionné de
cyclisme ça vous fait quoi de voir ses
coureurs
jay parini ces cas l'union ici dans
votre ville je les avais une joie dans
pas mal de villes comme je suis pas mal
le tour de france mais
les voir dans 20 communes c'est une
fierté personnelle fierté collective
pour notre commune pour la mettre en
valeur pour la valoriser mais je
regarderai
un grand souvenir en tant qu'élu
c'est la fin de ce paris nice dans les
yvelines rendez vous l'année prochaine
pour une nouvelle édition le département
à une convention avec ice aux jusqu'en
2025 et c'est la fin de ce journal belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]